hey guys what is going on welcome to the
tenth tkinter mega series tutorial video
in the last video we basically plotted
up our matplotlib graph here but we need
to make a few small changes to the graph
just cuz I think it's a little messy at
the moment one we want to make the graph
a bit bigger but also we want to that we
kind of want this I'd rather this be a
line then scatter plot now you can leave
it as a scatter plot like I was saying I
leave the scatter plot basically like
this on my website I kind of like it but
you need to have the graph pretty long
to do that otherwise it gets messy so
this is pure tick data right so this
shows every trade where is this
depending on the zoom it shows a
different amount of data otherwise it's
you know basically average data so
that's that so let's go ahead and get
started making this graph a little
better so if you're not too familiar
with matplotlib I do have a massive
series on matplotlib customization so if
you want to learn more about exactly
what we're doing I highly suggest you
check that out I'll explain a little bit
as to what the code does but if you want
to know like exactly how all this stuff
works I highly suggest you check out
that series if I recall I'll put a link
to it in the description chances are I
forget so remind me if you want to see
it I will put it in so living right
along the first thing that we really
need to change here is let's go to the
very top and our figure size is a 5 by 5
we can start by making that first of all
more like a 5 by 4 but I would say maybe
a 6 by 4 um so let's save and run that
really quick and just see what we think
because that should change a bit of the
size right so the graph if the graph is
a bit too big the graph will um kind of
affect the actual size of everything so
if you want you can make that graph
fairly large now I'm trying to think of
where the best place for us to because
we can you can define
find like the size of your actual
application really down here I think you
just do geometry or something like that
equals but I think our graph really can
specify that and so let's do let's do
for now um ten by six see if we get away
with a decent chart for now
well actually we will change that
eventually to something better will make
the actual application the size not the
chart and the chart will will size to
the application that way you go to a
different page and there's no graph on
that page the application doesn't like
shrink on you that looks kind of bad so
anyways that's that's a little bit
better of a size I would say so cool so
back to home and now we disagree and the
application exits so uh okay so now what
do we want to do about our graph so
we're going to come up first of all we
are style using so that's good um and
now our graph what we're going to go
ahead and do is we want to add first of
all some of some notation but also um
let's do okay so we've got buys price uh
then we can we can specify a color here
now you can do something as simple as
let's say buys we would call green okay
we'll just leave that for now and then
we'll also add a label and we'll call
that buys and then we'll come down here
into the exact same thing only cells and
whoops that needs to be red
okay so we've got plot plot also we can
go ahead and we can add a title let's
say to our graph we say the title is a
BC prices Bitcoin actually be to cVTC
USD prices something like that and then
we can say a dot set underscore title
the title and now let's look at our
graph at this point agree and you can
see that we've now switched to lines and
uh you've got the more
um we got green and red to denote and
we've got prices cool
now the other thing that we kind of need
is a label here a legend rather so we
might close that close here and we would
want to add a legend so basically after
the plotting with labels we would add
something like this a dot legend
we're going to use a be box underscore
to underscore anchor um and actually
here here's what I'll do for you guys uh
what I think we should get away with
this hey dot legend let's try that for
now just to show you the most basic
legend okay so there's a little legend
here the problem with this legend for
the most part is the following it can
cover over data now we've got this chart
massively updating I think every two
seconds or something but it can cover
over that data and that's kind of
annoying so what you can do instead is
use some fancy code now this is the code
I'm not going to explain if you want to
know more about it check out the series
I have so instead we'll do this B box to
anchor and then we're gonna say that
and then the locations basically zero
one point will do zero to one and then
point one zero two then we're going to
say the location is the third a possible
location then we're going to say n call
equals two and finally the border AXYZ
pad is zero that should work let's try
that and see what we get forget some
nastiness or some positiveness awesome
so now we've got buys and sells at the
upper left hand corner so now they
literally cannot get in the way so
that's cool so the other thing that I
always think is kind of cool um I don't
have it yet I wouldn't mind having it
those like whenever they display the
most recent price like over on the edge
of the graph I just eat that right up I
think that's cute
I wouldn't mind something like that um
so you could do some
but we're not gonna do that right here
but what we can do is see you've got BC
BC with the prices what you can do is
you can do something like this you could
say that's what the title equals and
then we could say um let's add a new
line and then last price : and then
we'll do space plus the string version
of data price so that's data it's
referencing the full pandas dataframe
not just buys not just sells um
data price and then we would just want
the lastest element now since we're
referencing 2000 that would mean the
last element would either be negative 1
or 1999 now let's try negative 1 first
though and make sure it's see if we get
away with that we did not right key
error because of it's actually a data
frame so let's let's do this instead 99
ok so now we get even better last price
and then maybe while I'm if you happen
that we'll get an update we'll see um
but anyway that's just some general
customization that we can do I am NOT a
fan of the whole green and red so I'm
going to also go ahead and change those
colors into this is a sea of BTC client
and I prefer these colors this blue and
it's blue so I'm going to change them
feel free to change them to whatever
color you want does no matter but
instead of just simple character letters
to define colors we can do hex colors
like so and for one version of a pretty
blue 0 0 a 3 E 0 and another pretty
color would be a number or pound sign 1
8 3 a 5 4 save and run that really quick
and we have a slightly better looking
colors at least in my opinion
now again you might want to keep the
scatter plot idea you might want to do
the lines I like the lines because
they're just a little slightly more
coherent when you're looking at a graph
like this one where there's a lot
there's 2,000 data points here so it's a
little hard for your eyes to know like
the proper order when you turn them into
lines it's very easy I think to see so
anyway I think price just changed I'm
not positive and my eyes might be
playing tricks on me
so anyways um so that's it for this one
um we've got a decent live graph so now
some of the new things that we want or
some of the things that we need to do at
least in the future is we want to be
able to live graphs are great 2000 data
points cool but this is you know the
last 30 minutes basically if prices and
2000 is the max that they'll give you so
if there's like say high volatility at
the moment this is 30 minutes but you
might only get 5 minutes if it's really
volatile and there's a lot of volume in
the market so so right now it's okay but
many times it won't be ok so what we
want to do is have longer data frame or
data sets better time frames there we go
that's the right word we want longer
time frames and so there's all kinds of
places where you can pull historical
data but we're going to use a sea of BTC
I have a lot of historical data there we
actually have data all the way down to
tick all through hit well not all three
history since we started so really about
four or five months maybe six months
worth I can't remember
we've got tick data depth data basically
everything you could possibly want so
we're going to use CMB TC server you do
not need an account or anything like
that there may come a time when I the
right now the data that we will use is
actual real time data might come a time
where I kind of delay that data or at
least slow it down from updating just
because the processing requirements are
pretty high so yeah keep that in mind
this might not be the perfect data I'll
try to add an annotation if I ever
change it but for now the data is
actually good data it's live from all of
the servers so yeah keep that in mind so
anyways that's it for this one if
guys have any questions or comments feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching things for
all the support subscriptions till next
time